My goal this year with the show is to
expand on even more topics we discussed
as well as the people that we're talking
to.
Yes,
we absolutely hit our stride by calling
out regressive bullshit and by
addressing the regressives,
the tide is actually turning.
People are finally standing up to their
insincere attacks and realizing that
liberalism is about the rights of
individuals before that of the group,
so if you truly believe in equality for
women,
then you have to defend their individual
rights,
whether it's to wear what they want,
drive a car or marry who they choose
regardless of their religious or
cultural background.
I said there was an awakening months ago
and it's pretty undeniable right now,
right?
That doesn't mean we can rest though.
If anything,
it means we have to dig in deeper and
keep calling out regressive nonsense
when we see it,
but as I've also said from day one,
I want this show to be a place for big
ideas of all kinds.
Over the course of the next few weeks,
I'm going to talk to people from hugely
different walks of life,
conservative radio talk,
show host,
Larry Elder,
science writer and skeptic Michael
Shermer and former leader of the English
Defense League,
Tommy Robinson,
just to name a few.
We're going to go big on topics ranging
from the election to science to
spirituality and more.
We're kicking off the year with CNN.
Don Lemon.
Love him or hate him.
Don is one of the few people in
mainstream media not afraid to say what
he thinks,
and he often pays for it via criticism
from both sides of the aisle.
Not only does he host his own nightly
show,
but he also reports on location from
natural disasters,
cohosts electoral debates,
and as even forigin unlikely friendship
with Glenn back along the way.
I know when we see these people on tv,
we have a way of thinking that they
aren't even human,
that they're just robots or something,
but I can assure you from personal
experience that with done what you see
is what you get.
We can always mark mainstream media and
we absolutely should.
Trust me,
I've made plenty of jokes at CNNS
expense.
Just check my twitter feed at the same
time.
We should acknowledge though that there
are many journalists in the mainstream
media trying to do good work while
online media has changed the way we get
the news.
I think one of the big lessons from 2015
is how online media could also be full
of crap.
Just because something isn't mainstream
doesn't mean it doesn't push a
narrative,
distort facts or outright lie.
As 2016 begins.
Let's all continue to shed light on
issues we care about.
Talk about difficult topics in an honest
way and see if we can make the
conversations in our lives a little more
enlightened.
All right.
My guest this week is the host of CNN
tonight.
Self proclaimed king of twitter,
and one of the few guys in Cable News,
not afraid to tell you what he really
thinks.
Don Lemon.
What's going on?
It's called CNN tonight with Don Lemon.
Okay.
Oh,
with Don Lemon.
With don limit.
How long did you have to fight to get
that in there?
Not that I'm picky.
Listen,
it's everything is important.
It all matters.
Dave Rubin,
how are you?
I'm doing good.
It actually does all matter and it's
funny that you say that because that I
think that's a good place to start
because you have been on this upward
thing forever.
We've known each other for probably like
four or five years now.
And you did my old Sirius xm show a long
time ago and,
and you were,
you were subbing in for a lot of people.
You were jumping around show to show,
but you have your own gig now.
Pretty good,
right?
It is pretty good.
I mean,
it's weird because people will say
you've been on this upward trajectory,
blah,
blah blah.
And it doesn't feel that way when you're
living it.
Right.
I'm still the same guy.
I'm still feels the same.
And um,
so,
you know,
the struggle is real,
but it's great to be in prime time on a
major network.
I mean,
you know,
you kind of,
it doesn't get any better than this.
A show with my name on it there.
I have no complaints and very.
I live every moment in gratitude right
now.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's a lot of stuff I want it to have
the first show of the year with you
because you're in the thick of it,
right?
Like every time I turn on the news and
something's going down somewhere,
they send you there or you're at the
studio or you're interviewing somebody.
So I thought you'd be the perfect person
to sort of kick the year off with.
But let's get a little bit first.
It wasn't the day to day operations.
So you have your show at night.
What's going on in the world of Don
Lemon all day long?
Well it depends on,
it depends on the day,
but I mean pretty much every night I'm
on the air at 10:00
PM and every night between seven and
eight I have a rundown meeting and every
single morning at 10:30
I have an editorial meeting and then
sometimes up I try to do the network,
a editorial call at nine,
so it can be a very long day.
And then I do radio on some mornings at
seven.
This is all eastern time?
Yeah,
about seven,
seven,
15 eastern time.
So it depends,
if it's a day I do radio,
I'm up at 6:45,
7:00
and I'm giving an editorial and the time
during the morning show and then I try
to read in from then and reads the
papers are at my door and then uh,
I try to stay awake and if I do,
I do the 9:00
editorial call and then if I don't,
I wake up at 10:30
for my shows,
editorial call and then I'll try to go
back to sleep.
But then sometimes other shows will call
and ask me to do live shots to do
something I cover the night before I'm
going to cover the that night or I'll do
an interview with Donald Trump or are
coming to a taping like I did today with
Rand Paul.
It just really depends.
So there's no set schedule.
So sometimes I get to sleep.
Other times I don't.
And um,
that's it.
And so usually usually I'm here,
I try to be,
unless I don't have any sleep,
the latest I'll get and it's probably
like six or 6:30.
But usually I try to get in about four,
4:30.
And you're taking,
you're taking naps in the.
That is your office right there.
I saw you at Lsu blanket.
So you do take naps.
Ouch.
Just before,
uh,
you just before we hooked up on skype.
Yeah,
we connected on skype.
Be careful,
be careful
out and buy a,
you know crystal,
right?
I do,
yeah.
Crystal came in and said,
hey,
what are you doing?
Don't go to sleep.
You've got to skype with Dave Rubin and
15.
I'm like,
I know,
I know Dave.
And he'll be fine.
He'll be fine.
So it's funny even the way that you,
you started saying hook up there and
then you immediately have to hedge your
bets because you're one of these people.
And I want to talk about this a little
later on that everything that you say
becomes like this sort of hot button
thing.
Uh,
but before we,
before we delve into all that stuff,
um,
how much news do you actually have to
consume every day?
Because I know I do an interview show
once a week,
but I'm in the news constantly.
I'm always paying attention to this
stuff and on twitter and during this
whole thing,
and there's a certain amount of
bandwidth I think,
that you only have in your brain to
absorb all this stuff,
but you have to know sort of all the
stuff that's going on all the time.
That's a very good point.
Um,
and sometimes I,
can,
I,
I consume so much that I forget,
right?
Like,
Oh yeah,
I knew that.
Like someone will say something and then
I'll go,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
I knew like,
like today I was sent out a note on
Wayne Lapierre's flip flop on background
checks.
Yeah.
Then someone else reminded me that we
did it before and I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that's right.
We did do that before.
And then I looked at why he did it.
So there's a,
you know,
he has a perfectly legitimate
explanation in his head why he did it.
But sometimes you just forget.
So,
um,
what I try to do quite honestly is not
to,
um,
I try to be informed without being
inundated because you don't have to know
every single thing that's going on in
the world and I don't.
My show doesn't cover every single thing
that's going on in the world.
I don't do a traditional rundown new
show like stack,
like now this,
now this,
now this is pretty much a theme and it
is the biggest story of the day or the
hottest topic or the talker of the day.
And usually we try not to do too many
subjects are we try to make them all
relate and we don't do a lot of stars.
Like traditionally,
you know,
when peers was here and when Larry was
here,
the hours that I'm in now or like very
star heavy and focused and they didn't
do very well.
And so we do watercooler talk,
provocative conversation,
have conversations that people will have
at home but not necessarily on
television.
And it's paid off.
And thank goodness our ratings are
great.
We're doing great and you know,
we're still going.
Yeah.
How much of that comes directly from
you?
Because I remember when,
when you did my show way back when,
whatever that was,
four or five years ago,
I think that same week that we met you
had subbed in for joy Bihar over on Hln
and I remember we were having a drink
and you were saying how much you like
that because it gave you a chance to
sort of be yourself and get out of the
kind of traditional newsman thing.
So are all these decisions in terms of
the format and all that,
is that all coming directly from you?
Well
shared.
A lot of it comes from me and a lot of
it comes from the,
the team,
um,
our staff,
the producers and our executive producer
Jonathan Wall who's really great with
ideas.
And then I'll have ideas as well.
It depends on the day.
Sometimes like now you know,
it's a no brainer.
The president is having this big town
hall with Anderson this week.
He made,
he did the Senate at the house.
We're going to talk about guns,
right?
We're going to talk about a executive
orders.
Uh,
and,
and so it's pretty easy.
We're going to talk about what's
happening in Oregon,
so sometimes it's just pretty self
explanatory.
It's our show.
It's great to finally have a show,
uh,
and that I don't have to call a newscast
because it's not a newscast,
although when it needs to be,
we can quickly become a newscast that we
can give you.
I can give you the 32nd or 15 second
elevator pitch between one floor,
biggest story of the day or biggest
talkers.
Otherwise it does not fit.
I don't care if you're a movie star,
I don't care who you are,
if it's not,
if it has nothing to do with the news
that it's not relevant,
it's not coming on the show.
That simple.
Alright.
So before we get into all the meat and
we're going to talk politics and guns
and all that kind of stuff,
uh,
how did you get into this thing?
Did you always want to be on TV?
Did you always want to be a news guy?
What,
what brought little don lemon to be over
at Time Warner Center right now?
I was always curious as a kid and um,
when we would go out and about my
parents,
I write about this in my book,
which is called transparent by the way
that I would just talk to everybody and,
you know,
my mom would like come and grab me in
the restaurant.
My Dad would always say,
don't teach them to be afraid of people.
And my mom said after that conversation
she just let me go.
So I would just ask people like,
what are you here?
Are you on vacation when you're doing?
I've just always been curious.
I don't necessarily think that I wanted
to be on television,
although I liked it.
Um,
I always wanted to be a journalist and
you know,
people remind me when I go home for
holidays or just to visit my family that
you remember even in college,
used to bring the camera to school.
Remember we taped this fake show when
you were a kid.
You remember you used to carry this
camera around and then a or do you
remember?
We had you anchor our high school and so
I forgot a lot of those things.
And so it's always been there.
Yeah.
So let's talk about the gay thing for
justice.
Sick,
because I don't think we had about you.
Let's talk about your gay thing for a
second.
We can talk about mine too if you want.
Um,
there's so much I can go because let me
see that hand.
Raise your left hand.
Oh yeah.
I got one of these.
Wow.
Yeah.
But that's okay.
Go ahead.
You can get one too.
Didn't you just say,
I think if I'm not mistaken,
just on air.
A couple of days ago you said to
somebody,
why would you get married?
Didn't you say that to Brook or
somebody?
Oh,
there's somebody in the crowd.
Why would you get married?
I just think that I don't want to create
another controversy.
I don't see the need to run off and get
married right away or ever.
And I don't know if I'm the marrying
kind.
Yeah.
That said,
listen,
my whole thing,
and I'm pretty sure you'll agree with me
on this,
is that we should just have the right.
The same rate that everybody else has
this.
Yeah.
If you want to do it,
do it.
If you don't want to do it,
don't do it.
Like that's it.
But that's why I don't even want to talk
about the gay thing much.
So we could literally do just a minute
on this,
but I know I'm just messing with you
because we know each other.
No,
no,
I know,
but like to me like,
and we've talked about this privately,
but like it's exhausting talking about
the gay thing.
Gay people shouldn't have to think about
it any more than straight people should
have to think about their sexuality or
of that.
But anyway,
you basically came out when your book
came out,
so it was about four years ago,
is that right?
Okay.
Most professionally,
yeah,
it was 2011.
It was funny because I was talking to a
friend in Chicago,
which was before I came to work at CNN
and he said,
he goes,
I know people were saying don lemon came
out and he's like,
what do you mean?
Downloading came out dot limon has
always been out.
So,
you know,
since I've been out since my twenties,
but it wasn't something that I talked
about on the air or shared publicly,
but my bosses knew I would bring my
boyfriends to the Christmas party.
I mean it wasn't a big deal,
but the public didn't know.
I would host events for like gay events
in Chicago and now basically out.
So when people say,
you know,
it took you 45 years to come out,
I'm like,
well,
not really.
I think I had to do it because there was
so much confusion.
And when you're in the public eye,
I think it's important that you say,
uh,
at least when I came out that you sort
of,
you had to make a declaration because
it's important for young people who are
at home,
people who may be struggling,
people who may have doubt.
And I want people to know like,
Hey,
you can be a gay person and you can host
a show on CNN.
And it is okay.
Yeah.
So that's the part that I wanted to talk
about because this is exactly what we
talked about four years ago,
that there was so much going on with gay
rights.
There was so much happening at the
moment and in a way as a public person,
it's sort of like this extra pressure of
if I'm going to talk about this on air,
I have to be authentic about it.
Right?
Like,
how much of that did you actually really
feel?
Well,
I,
no one forced me.
I started writing a book about,
you know,
sort of my exploits as a journalist and
writing about my childhood and how I
grew up and whatever.
And I just thought it would be
disingenuous to write a book like that
and not included.
So it's like,
you know,
telling everything about your life
except for that,
you know,
one important thing.
That one,
that one thing that is really important,
it's not all of who I am.
Um,
but it is an important part of my life.
And I think it's important again,
for other people to be able to see
someone like me or like a Dave Rubin
who,
who people who are successful and who
just happened to be gay.
So yeah,
there was a lot of pressure on it,
on me and there was a lot of pressure
to,
as a person of color to come out.
Yeah.
Isn't it cool how it's so irrelevant.
I mean,
that's even why I'm prefacing this by
saying,
let's put two seconds.
Yeah.
He enlisted.
Let me tell you,
it's irrelevant to you and it's
irrelevant to many people who live in
big cities like you're in la now.
I'm in New York and when we met with you
in New York,
um,
so for us it's easy because there I am,
there is no space place where I am in
the closet.
My entire team knows,
the audience knows,
my family knows people at the
barbershop.
No.
Like I don't really care what you know,
bob at the barbershop thinks about me or
of,
of gay people.
I'm,
I am completely out.
And that is to a lot of people,
that's not reality.
And it's strange to certain people,
especially a certain demographics and
certain ethnicities,
people aren't quite that out yet.
I think it's easier for you as a white
man to be out.
Yeah.
Alright.
Well
we'll.
Okay.
So we'll,
we'll delve into some of the racial
stuff.
So my,
my last thing on the gay thing is do you
think there is something about gay
people in general that there are so many
out gay people in news right now?
I mean,
you take you and you take cheever and
Anderson and Rachel Maddow and Thomas
Robertson and you know,
there's a half out guy on Fox.
Even.
He may be out already.
I'm not sure.
I'm not even going to name them,
don't even have to smile or look at the
caviar or whatever.
But my point is that for some reason,
you know Riley,
yeah,
he's definitely gay.
That guy.
I'll tell you no,
but my point that there's a lot of out
people that people get there,
there's something comforting in a weird
way or something about gay people.
It would be my aunt.
Anything there?
Yes.
There's something comforting about gay
people.
We're loving people,
loving people,
but here's the thing,
I don't think,
Dave,
that those numbers are any different
than any other profession.
I think that there have been some people
who are brave enough to step up in this
profession because I feel that if you're
a journalist,
you take an oath.
I'm much like you do.
If you have a juris doctorate,
when you become an attorney,
have you haven't.
When you,
you know,
you take the medical oath when you
become a doctor.
I think that journalists really feel
that,
you know,
you have an obligation to inform people.
You have an obligation to tell the
truth.
You have an obligation to be as unbiased
and objective as any human being can be.
So I think that when you're in this
business,
in order to get the truth from people,
in order to be truthful,
you have to live who you are and if you
can put different rules on,
uh,
other people that you put on yourself.
And so I think that maybe people are
just more visible because it's a visible
medium obviously.
Um,
and I just think that we sort of take
that oath,
but I don't,
I think there are plenty of gay doctors,
there are plenty of gay lawyers,
there are plenty of gay politicians as
we have seen plenty of gay people in the
clergy and on and on and on.
I just,
I don't think it's any different.
I just think that we happen to be more
visible.
For the record.
I have a friend who's a gay janitor,
so we are out.
We're in every occupation that they're.
Yeah,
I know gay athletes,
I know gay and everything.
So there you go.
Alright.
So that's it for the gay thing.
Forget about that.
Let's move on.
Let's.
All right,
so cable news,
you got to ring on your finger.
Stop it with me.
It's enough already.
Um,
so cable news,
what do you make of the general state of
Cable News?
Because it gets a lot of crap at,
you know,
from everybody all the time.
And I'm not talking about you
specifically,
but in general you say cable news and
people start freaking out,
right?
So what do you make of the general like
sense of Cable News?
Well,
I think it's,
you know,
obviously it's an easy target,
right?
The media,
excuse me,
the media is always an easy target and
so when you're in that easy target that
happens to be on 24 hours a day,
you're going to be an even bigger
target.
And when you're on and there is no
script there,
you know,
then you're an even bigger target
because we are human and sometimes many
times,
most times there are no words in box to
read when you're in cable.
Now if you're on broadcast,
it's a whole different story.
If you're doing an evening broadcast in
national or local,
everything is scripted for you.
You read,
if you're doing a 30 minute newscast,
maybe you read at the most five to seven
minutes of copy,
right?
You're saying,
oh,
the big story out West was the flooding
and Blah about Dave Rubin joins us,
uh,
with the latest Dave,
what do you know?
Boom.
And then that's it.
And then you go,
thank you dave.
And now let's talk about the president's
reform on gun control.
And you even talk like this,
it's a very specific answer for you and
blah,
blah.
And all you're saying is thank you.
And the most that you'll say is
incredible report,
Bob Blah.
That's it.
When your cable,
you're saying,
no,
listen,
that's not right.
The facts aren't there.
Hold on,
let me get my information where the
president said back in such and such,
that's another.
People are screaming right now and
you're like,
wait,
now you talk.
Wait,
wait.
Now you talk.
So there's a lot more room for error.
There's a lot more people talking back
and forth.
It's a lot more interesting to watch.
So of course people are gonna,
you know,
we're going to be a target and sometimes
deservedly so.
Most of the time.
Not really because we're just,
we're just,
we just happen to be on television in
very real moments a lot of the time.
Yeah.
So to that point,
how often,
because I right now in this very second,
I have an ifb in my ear just so that I
can hear you,
because it's the nature of how we're
doing skype.
I don't think you have one in,
right?
You're,
you're just doing the skype off the
computer.
But one of the things,
yeah,
they're okay.
We have proof.
But one of the things I hear all the
time,
and I think I probably thought this too,
is that when you're on Cable News,
you're on television in general.
There is someone in your rear always
barking orders at you.
How,
how often is that actually true for you
that,
that you're doing your broadcast and
someone is actually telling you what to
say.
And I'm not talking about the technical
stuff.
Cut to commercial.
I mean,
you know,
sometimes people tell you what to say
and so sometimes you're like,
Amen.
Thank you.
Sometimes people are correcting you.
Sometimes people are like,
they're your other ears are listening to
the guest.
And then someone will say,
well,
you know,
I'm a,
well,
it's gonna.
It's gonna Affect the fourth amendment.
And then so the producer will say,
the president never mentioned the fourth
amendment.
And you'll say,
hey,
listen to president ever mentioned the
fourth amendment.
Or sometimes you'll say,
um,
uh,
it was uh,
an unalienable right.
And then the producer will say in
Elliot,
right?
So just little things,
or,
um,
I always like to tell people that,
well,
this recent example is we go on the air,
everything is ready in the show,
you know,
the openness scripted,
right?
And it's like,
you know,
blah,
blah.
Donald trump.
Is that a rally in Iowa?
And we know this is CNN tonight.
I'm Don Lemon,
right?
And then all of a sudden that,
you know,
introduce now let's go to our panel.
Dave Ruben is here,
Ryan.
Liz is here and you know,
Kaylee Macanese here,
so panel.
And then someone will say,
stop.
And I'll go,
oh standby.
I'll say.
And then they'll roll the breaking news
animation.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
And they'll go breaking news,
breaking news.
And they'll say,
uh,
there's been a plane that's been
diverted.
You say there's been a plane that's been
And then as you're talking they'll say,
okay,
now go with prompter.
And so all of this stuff you are talking
and then you look up and they say,
okay,
joining us on the phone.
And they'll say,
Bob Williams,
they'll say Bob Williams from Nebraska,
from Nebraska,
and so you know,
and sometimes you'll be in the middle of
a sentence and people will talk to you.
So it does happen.
People at home think you're stupid,
but actually you're not that stupid.
You're just like,
uh.
So that's it.
And that's why I wanted to ask you that
because I think there's this sense out
there that you're getting orders of what
you can and should say.
And what you're really saying is it's
technical stuff.
It's stuff because we have a live
program and maybe they're fact checking
you,
but they're not being like,
Don,
you better tell him or say saving you
buy.
Wait,
whoa.
Explain what you meant by that.
And you're like,
oh,
what I meant was
because someone might misconstrue it,
but it doesn't really.
Everything gets misconstrued and
everything now gets taken out of
context.
Like I can say,
okay Dave,
let's not talk about the gay thing.
Right?
And then.
So we'll just take that and say,
oh,
Don Lemon zest,
shamed of being gay.
And you're like,
no.
That was like a habit.
The sentence in an entire conversation
that we had and then it builds upon
itself and it keeps building.
It's like a wildfire and by the time it
gets to the end it has absolutely
nothing to do with what you said and
then people believe it because of social
media.
It's really kind of ridiculous.
I want to explore that somehow.
Yeah,
I think she didn't investigate that.
Well.
It's something that we've been talking
about here a lot because one of the
things that I'm seeing all the time now
and unfortunately I see this more on the
left,
is people being misquoted all the time
and no matter what you say and so that
it's a good segway actually because I
think you,
in terms of the mainstream media people,
you're the victim of this all the time.
I mean,
every time I open up mediate,
Don Lemon says this,
Don Lemon,
this that,
or go back and look at the whole thing
of what I said and you're like,
wait a minute.
That's not what happened at all dot.
I don't know if that kind of time to
listen to the context.
What do you things to do?
But,
but that's exactly what your point is,
that they get you on the,
on the one liner,
they know that nobody's going to go back
and watch the two minutes before the two
minutes after.
So for you,
how,
how aware of that do you have to be and
how much are you thinking the whole
time?
Oh,
I better not go there even though it's
what I really believe or it's what I
want to say.
Well,
I'm aware a little bit,
but um,
I can't do that to myself.
I don't,
I don't want to censor myself that way
because then you're not authentic.
And I think that,
you know,
whatever success I've achieved,
I think it's been through authenticity.
And so if I was worried about every
single word and how it's going to be,
of course you want to be smart,
right?
And you want to be buttoned up in a
certain way or have your facts straight.
I don't want to do that.
And so if you want to take me out of
context and that's your business.
Um,
and I think for the most part smart
people,
the viewers aren't dumb.
They,
they understand what's happening in the
stuff that happens online,
especially like twitter and all those.
It doesn't usually translate to
television.
It certainly doesn't translate into
ratings and it doesn't translate into
credibility.
So you know,
you just,
it's wonderful that I work for a network
and a boss who says constantly ignore
the noise.
You guys are doing great.
The network is doing great.
Our story is great right now.
Continue the momentum,
be yourself,
be smart,
keep moving and don't even read.
It doesn't even matter if we tweet or
not or we don't have to read it.
It's a,
it's amazing and wonderful.
We're in a great spot right now and
seeing it so we don't worry about that.
Right.
It's kind of funny because on the social
media side,
you know,
like I,
I could pick something like when you
said that the black hole thing during
the,
the plane thing and think you know,
you're on air for hours,
you're talking about all of this stuff.
You're just throwing out,
you know,
somebody said it could be a black hole,
like you weren't saying it's in a black
hole or whatever it is.
And then next thing you know don lemon
is trending and all that.
So you really,
you really can just put it aside.
No,
I mean I can because we listened.
We,
I've talked about this ad Nauseum at the
New York Times.
Did a thing on it.
It's not,
it's not that you believe those things.
We had a thing called crazy conspiracy
theories that people were sending to us.
Yeah.
So one of those was that it was a
question from a viewer.
That's it.
I've read the question from a viewer and
that was the end of story and that took
on a life of its own,
but so be it.
It may be famous,
but it's not.
It did not come from me.
That's [inaudible] positing that I'm
saying,
Hey,
look this,
this is what viewers are saying.
They were also seeing.
It was in a hangar somewhere that we
mentioned that there were also saying
that it was a,
it was flown.
Someone else took it and hijack did.
There were a number of different things
that were said about it,
all of which we talked about on social
media.
That one just happened to get picked up.
Yeah.
You know,
at the top of the show,
I did a little piece on how I was saying
we need mainstream media,
but we also need online media because I
do believe we need both for different
reasons and different corporate
interests and all that.
I think.
I think we look as the online guy and
the and the mainstream guy.
We need more.
We need more honest online people.
We need online people,
online people who will actually do their
homework,
who will call,
who will not write an article off of
someone else's article off of someone
else's opinion of what someone else did
online.
People who actually saw the entire
segment in context to do their job,
not just like lazy people are lazy and
they just go,
oh,
you know,
I'm such and such.
Whatever.
Yeah.
He said that and you're like,
no,
that's not so.
It's.
And it's Kinda hard for us,
for those of us who are in more
traditional media to chase all of those
things down and it's just not worth it.
Yeah.
I mean,
you literally took the words out of my
mouth.
That's exactly what I'm saying because I
think at some point there was the online
media,
dede was doing a lot of good stuff
getting to stories that maybe hadn't
bubbled up to you guys yet.
And yet somehow in the last year or two,
there's so many trashy sites that are
just waiting for,
for not,
not just the,
you know,
the on air guys,
but for politicians to just find any
little thing that they can say and run
with that just so that they can get
clicks and they're no longer doing a
service either.
Well,
we call it click,
Click Bait.
We're at,
at the point in here at CNN where we
realized that I'm clickbait.
Just say Don Lemon and people are going
to click on it.
Yeah.
So they will say don lemon and then
anything.
But um,
what I wanted to say is,
oh,
when you talk about online people,
so have you ever worked for a
traditional network where you work for
serious?
So that was,
I would imagine that's pretty.
Yeah,
that was corporate.
That was corporate is so rigorous here
before I can say anything on the air as
a fact or present something.
It's got to go through our fact checkers
is it has to go through standards and
practices.
You know,
what our definition of what we're
talking about,
the guys in Oregon,
what our definition of terrorism is,
all of those things,
um,
how we confirm things we had the other
night when Natalie Cole died,
everyone was reporting Natalie Cole
died,
but we couldn't get in touch with her,
her publicist,
the publicist was busy and every time we
call the phone was busy.
The email,
I guess we could not report that CNN
would not report that until we heard
from an official person online.
People don't have those,
you know,
they don't have to climb those hurdles.
And I think that's sad and missing
because listen,
we don't have to be first,
we just want to be accurate and I wish
like,
I wish the online people want it to be
more accurate than first or funny or
opinionated.
Yeah,
I totally hear you.
I,
I feel like I sort of exist in between
those two worlds and I'm,
I'm just trying to do what you're saying
which is,
which is be honest and have honest
conversations.
And even though I had one of these
things in my ear and nobody's yelling,
what did they tell you?
No,
uh,
nothing they're saying doing it.
You're doing a hell of a job.
That's what they just said.
Um,
so,
so the other thing that I think is
interesting about you is that you get
heat from both sides.
And I'm not talking about when they
misquote you,
now I'm talking about if you say
something,
for example,
about black lives matter or you're
taking a selfie right now.
I just wanted this for.
I'm going to do when I,
when I post online,
go ahead.
Nice.
So,
um,
that you get equal heat from both sides.
So if you take a black lives matter,
for example,
there's a certain amount of racist
people who will look at you as a,
as a black man,
and they're going to just say racist
shit,
that's just going to come no matter
what.
And then there'll be people when you've
said things that haven't been,
you know,
sort of in lock step with,
with the movement that'll say you're an
uncle Tom.
And I'm only using that word because
when I googled you,
it was one of the first words that came
up,
uh,
that Don Lemon is a trademark.
That word.
But go ahead.
Yeah.
That don lemon is an uncle Tom.
But to me it seems like you're usually
doing good stuff when people on both
sides are attacking you and that's what
you're getting all the time,
right?
Well,
yes.
And the thing that people.
Here's the thing that when I,
when we talk about double standards and
expectations of people,
uh,
as a person of color,
well,
someone just to say someone not of
color,
people don't expect you to be the
spokesman for all white men,
right?
Are All,
thank God they don't even expect you to
be the spokesman for gay people.
I got it.
Somehow.
There's this expectation of me to be the
spokesman for black people or gay people
and I neither what?
I'm the spokesman for his information
and truth,
and so if black lives matter does
something that is worthy of criticism
than it is my job as a journalist to
give that criticism because no movement
is perfect.
Even the civil rights movement was a
perfect and received that share of
criticism.
So there's a black person in this
position and the only one who is in
prime time on a cable network.
When people see that coming from me,
they're like,
how dare he?
Well,
I'm not doing that.
I'm doing my job.
That is what I'm supposed to do.
So,
and if someone who is white sees me
talking about black lives matter and in
a way that's positive,
then of course I agree with them so you
know I can't win.
And so the.
The point is not to be an advocate or
someone who is an activist.
My point is to be a journalist.
The I get those races and they get this
homophobia,
sexism,
but at the end of the day,
what I'm giving his information,
or if I say,
um,
you know,
uh,
I just received information that,
you know,
Michael,
that the cop in the Michael Brown case
is not going to be indicted.
That word is going to come out.
People who want him to be indicted or
going to get upset and call me an uncle
Tom because it came out of my mouth.
And then 20 minutes later when the guy
comes out and says,
there's no indictment,
no one goes,
oh,
he was right.
They just go,
oh,
he's covering that story.
I can't believe him,
you know?
So it's just,
it is what it is.
People take out their frustrations on
the person who was in front of them and
I haven't been that person.
And do you find that a lot of it,
it's odd that like with the uncle Tom
stuff,
that,
that comes from people on the left that
they would want you,
right?
The people on the left,
they should see you as an individual
except what they're seeing or what
they're complaining about is that you
should be this representative of black
America or whatever.
I find that the people who were supposed
to be the most tolerant are the least
because they,
they never consider that they in fact
may not be because they think that
everyone thinks like them.
Yeah,
and not everybody thinks like you.
So you know,
concern.
I find that,
listen,
I get it from all sides,
but I find that the people who are most
incredulous about things and many times
the most vocal are liberals.
Yeah.
And and many times for me as well,
African Americans,
because they're looking at me regardless
of the facts.
Even if the facts don't pan out,
even if,
if the evidence and all the
investigations and all the autopsies
show no hands up,
don't shoot.
I have to come on television and say
hands up,
don't shoot.
I can't do that.
That's not what the evidence shows.
So I have to say the evidence does not
show that.
So that never happened according to the
evidence.
I can't believe you.
You sell out and you're like,
well,
what do you want me to do?
Lie.
I can't lie.
Right?
And then that's exactly where they go.
Oh,
because he's getting
the information from his year,
which I think you've illustrated is
actually not the case.
Okay.
So a lot of people have been asking me
this on twitter and I thought you'd be
the perfect person to pose this question
to the way the media frames certain
things.
So the way the media frames black lives
matter versus how the media is now
framing this Oregon militia thing and we
don't have to get into the nitty gritty
of,
of every little instance that's
happening.
But a lot of people were saying,
you know,
that the media is not calling these
Oregon people.
They're not calling them terrorists.
And if this was a group of black people
or especially if this was a group of
Muslim people,
we would be calling them terrorists.
And I was googling the word terrorism
and you know,
it talks about intimidation or violence
and violence and to me it's a little
hazy whether them taking this building
where they had to use no force per se.
And apparently the building was just
open and yes,
they had guns and it's federal property,
it's all that,
whether it's actually terrorism.
And would the medium be treating it
differently if it was either black
people or Muslim people.
Why are you falling into that trap?
Dave Rubin,
I tell me why me out of this trap,
how about that?
So here's the,
the thing.
So I actually wrote an editorial saying
that it was terrorism in my editorial
for the Tom Joiner morning show.
And so,
um,
you know,
it was read by someone here at CNN and
they said,
well,
our definition of terrorism here at CNN
is different,
is that it has to be political,
it is political,
that's political,
but it also has to have someone who has
been hurt by it,
like physically hurt.
So it's not terrorism until someone has
actually hurt or killed or what have
you.
And I think that's part of the
definition here,
but according to the law enforcement
people I spoke to,
if you are doing something for a
political end or whatever that is
illegal in that manner than it is
terrorism.
So I have called a terrorism.
I've heard other people call it
terrorism.
I don't know how other media
organizations frame it,
but here at CNN I don't think there's a
double standard about what's going on
and what it is.
Now.
Here's the thing,
is it,
do I know that it.
Would it be different if it was Muslims
or if it was black,
black people?
Yeah,
of course.
I live in America.
I know that in this particular case.
So I have to have to hedge it and say
I'm not so sure.
And here's why.
Because it is in the middle of nowhere.
It's 280 miles from Portland,
Oregon.
The next biggest city Burns is what?
80 slash 30 or 80 miles away.
And no one really knows where Burns
Oregon is,
right?
So it is basically a truck stop,
not even a truck stop at a rest stop in
the middle of nowhere.
What the government is trying to do,
the FBI is trying to do is to avoid
another Ruby Ridge and another waco and
so it is the middle of winter.
Nobody's there.
Nobody is in danger of being hurt.
The best thing that these guys can do is
be ignored.
I hate that we even have to give them
media attention because they're Yahoo's.
They're not within their legal rights
for anything.
So I think what they're doing now is
perfectly fine.
Let them sit there in the middle of
winter and freeze their asses off and
fine.
If you want to stay down in the middle
of winter in that little crappy
building,
then that is your business.
Yes,
it is a federal building and they are
breaking the law and at some point they
will have to take care of it.
But I think at this point I think
they're actually doing the right thing.
As far as immediate reaction,
I don't.
I haven't seen any.
I don't know anyone who's called it like
a peaceful protest or what have you.
It's it is what it is.
It's people who are ignorant of the law
who have taken over a building and they
should pay for the pay,
the consequences when the time comes,
but right now I'd say ignore them.
Yeah,
and I'm pretty sure they're not going to
get what they want at the end of this.
That's usually how these things
and it's many of the people whose land
was saved by the government helping them
out years ago and now they want to
reclaim it and get the money back.
That the more money that was already
given to them,
they're just ignorant of the law.
If this was a building that mattered in
the middle of the city that mattered,
sure.
Reaction will be completely different
and there would be more direct threat to
Corbett direct threat.
Yes,
but I do think that they're getting a
pass there because of their religion.
They're not Muslim because they're white
non-african-american.
I do,
but I don't know how different the
reaction would really be.
I don't know because it's a building
that nobody cares about in the city,
in a place that nobody really cares
about it.
Yeah.
And it's only 15,
about 15 or so people who are actually
in that building.
It's not hundreds of people.
Yeah.
They're running out of snacks.
I heard.
So this thing can't last that long.
They're idiots.
All right.
So,
uh,
let's talk about some of the things that
bring us together because that,
you know,
what the audience is going to go now see
lemons looking at somebody who's giving
him the signal,
whether he can talk about it or not.
Someone is in my office,
but I'm just,
we're just laughing.
Um,
so one thing that you've done that I,
I really appreciate because it comes
completely with the spirit of how I've
done this show is you've really tried to
build bridges with people that perhaps
some might think you shouldn't get along
with or you shouldn't talk with.
So I've seen you a couple times with a
Glenn Beck and,
and I was tweeting up a storm the first
time I saw it because I thought this is
exactly what the news is supposed to be.
This is what not not reporting,
but this is what conversation is
supposed to be.
You guys come from very different
places,
you know,
he's a pure libertarian,
I suppose.
Uh,
your politics are different and you
know,
you're just trying to have the
conversation and that's what I'm trying
to do here.
And I thought it was pretty beautiful.
I was.
So I guess I don't even know what my
question is as much as I want to see
more of that.
Well,
he,
you say that our politics are different.
I'm not political.
I'm like the least political person that
you got on.
I swear I don't care about conservative
or liberal.
I think all politicians are full of it.
I think I'll go with you on that.
And I judge things on my own.
So,
you know,
especially coming from an African
American background,
African Americans are pretty liberal and
then some things and also very
conservative and many times conservative
socially when it comes to the church.
So you know,
you know,
for people to sit there and pretend
like,
oh,
where do those big liberals and they're
not,
and then you don't accept gay people and
then it.
So it's not true.
So I'm not,
I,
I am not political.
So when you say my politics are
different,
it's not,
I will listen.
I think the only way,
especially if it's someone you don't
agree with or if you consider them your
enemy or not on your side,
don't you want to know what they're
thinking?
I don't understand.
When people say,
I am never going to talk to them,
how could you?
Don't you dare sit down.
You knew how much crap I got because I
like I because I sat down twice with
Aaron Wilson and I went,
um,
I almost got the interviews between me,
uh,
George Stephanopoulos and one other
person.
I forget who it was and we all,
you know,
George ended up getting the interview.
I got so much guff because I wanted to
do an interview with him.
It's like,
well,
don't you want to hear from him?
Like even if you don't agree with them,
especially if you don't agree with them,
you want to hear his rationale and his
reasoning,
so it is never made sense to me to not
talk to someone who you disagree with.
Now that's it.
I think that people should be respectful
and they should be in their right minds,
but you know before you are,
when you're talking to them and if they
don't then they're outta here.
I'll cut you right off if you're.
Yeah,
if you're being an ignoramus,
I'm not dealing with it.
Yeah.
Well,
interestingly,
I wasn't even going to bring this up,
but a couple months ago,
maybe two months ago or so,
you had a Sam Harris who's been on my
show who's become a friend of mine and
Dean Obeidallah were on and they were,
they were debating this Islam and and
sort of,
you know,
religion verse people thing.
And in the midst of it,
Dean said something that I knew to be
implying that sam believed something
about all Muslims and I knew it to be
not true because I had sat there with
Sam and rehashed it.
He's rehashed it a thousand times.
And while it was infuriating aiding for
me to watch,
I thought,
all right,
at least they're having the
conversation.
So that's what you're just opening the
door for.
Yeah,
and the thing about that is,
is that we have to stop calling people,
you know,
Isms or obs,
phobias,
not homophobic or Islamophobic or
whatever because they want to have a
conversation.
That's part,
that's what we do is have a
conversation.
And when you have great minds,
like you know,
a Fried Zacharia or Sam Harris or
whomever who say,
yes,
there is a problem that must be
addressed in Islam and we have to figure
out how to do it.
When you have great minds like that,
those are the people that you should
listen to.
When you have people who say there is no
problem.
And by you saying this,
then you are as auto phobic,
then that person is very dangerous
because the evidence is there doesn't
mean that people in that religion or
that it doesn't mean that that Islam is
bad,
doesn't mean mean that Muslims are bad.
It doesn't mean that because we talk
about crime in that is committed mostly
by African Americans.
It doesn't mean that African Americans
are bad or that black people are bad.
It means that we were just having those
conversations and so we have to stop
that.
And,
and you know,
Matt,
I think that's why I can talk to someone
like a Glenn Beck is because,
you know,
I want to,
I would rather have common ground with
people or try to reach some sort of
common ground or consensus rather than
just having them an enemy,
keeping them at arm's length and not
being at the table.
That's what's happening in Washington
and with the Congress right now.
What good is that doing anybody?
Yeah.
So that's actually a perfect segue for
the political climate.
So let's just talk about that a little
bit.
So you've been in this for awhile.
It's pretty bad right now,
right?
Like,
could it get much worse?
I keep thinking that it's not going to
get much worse.
And now I realize we're in an election
year.
We've got this crazy thing with trump
right now.
That's me.
Yeah.
You just have to nod through this whole
thing probably.
But really like how much worse is this
thing gonna get before this election
comes?
I think it's going to get a lot worse
and I think um,
because of how much it's being amped up
on both sides.
So whoever's in the White House next is
going to have a huge challenge.
Like if a Democrat is in there,
all those people that have been read by
the right and by Donald Trump,
right?
Some people you can,
if you can just go hillary
and they go,
ah,
can't even get her name out,
right?
Say you say Donald Trump,
they go,
oh my God,
I hate that guy.
You can't even get their name out.
So I think people are becoming amped up
more than almost any election that I've
seen except for during the Obama
election.
It was pretty,
it was pretty crazy,
right?
Him and Sarah Pailin,
it was like,
wow.
In a weird way,
doesn't it seem like,
to me,
it seems like we were all on ecstasy
back then,
like it was like seven years besides the
past,
is that if we just romanticize the past,
it was bad.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on.
It was,
you know,
he wasn't,
he wasn't America and he was a Muslim.
He went to a madrasa.
Um,
what else?
Oh,
you know,
a socialist,
all that socialist,
all those things.
And then,
you know,
mccain couldn't find a running mate in
any found Sarah pay on it.
And then that was a disaster.
And then people said,
oh my God,
everybody was out to get Sarah Pailin.
And then as it turns out,
she was not as informed as she should
have been.
And so it was,
you know,
it was a little crazy.
Right?
All that said,
we didn't have a trump.
Right.
How do you deal with this trump thing?
Because one of the things that I've
noticed and,
and we've talked about it,
it makes me,
I love interviewing him.
It goes,
love it.
I,
I know.
I don't necessarily love what he says.
That's not.
Don't get me wrong.
The spectacle.
I loved new.
No,
I love interviewing him because you
don't know what he's going to say.
I love the back and forth.
I love the way his mind works.
Doesn't mean I agree with him.
When he's like,
excuse me,
Don.
You know,
people at home are like,
oh,
he cut you off inside.
I'm kind of laughing.
I'm,
oh my gosh.
And I'm like,
you know,
when he goes up,
excuse me,
done.
He is,
it's a bit comical sometimes he's,
he's a performer,
so I love interviewing him,
but that's about it.
So is that really though the secret
sauce to what he's doing that the rest
of these guys?
All of them,
pretty much.
I would argue that Bernie probably is
not as Bernie does seem like he's
speaking from the heart and he speaks in
a way that doesn't sound like a
politician,
but pretty much the rest of them,
they all just sound like politicians and
people are over that.
And because of that,
even when trump says crazy stuff,
it makes people like him,
like we had this like a thing that's
like eating itself constantly with him.
And because of that,
I mean,
I tell people this because I use it,
tick them off,
right?
They usually tell like people who are on
the left,
the president trump get used to it.
Oh Wow.
But it's,
you know,
I had never,
I had not underestimated him since he
got into the race because here's why.
And I said this from the beginning,
you can probably find it on tape
somewhere.
He's used to swimming in these New York
media waters.
Sharks,
right?
He knows how to handle them,
manipulate the media.
He knows how to cut a deal,
you know,
if you can say,
if you can make it there,
you can make it anywhere.
This guy has made it with help from his
dad.
Don't get me wrong,
but you know,
he,
um,
he's made it here.
He's become,
you know,
at the top of the food chain and the
media food chain here.
He knows how to deal with the media and
so,
and he's got a lot of money,
a lot of it,
of running for president is having a ton
of dough and he has a ton of dough and
he knows how to deal with people and he
has a good year on what people want to
hear.
So when he's in front of a crowd,
he's like,
oh,
they liked that,
huh?
And it gives them more or they don't
like that so much.
He changes the subject.
So having known all of that and being
here in the nineties and,
and knowing Donald Trump,
I was like,
this guy isn't going anywhere.
So yeah.
Yeah.
I'm all right.
I got just a couple more for you because
I know you have to actually be blowing
me off.
You have to be live on air.
Uh,
not too.
Not too long from now and about two
hours and 15.
Oh,
I got plenty.
I'll go.
Listen.
I'll talk as long as you want.
Um,
so,
uh,
how much do you think.
One of my major issues is when I watch
something live,
by the way,
I know we're not lying.
We're not.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
when I watched something like the,
uh,
you know,
the press club,
the yearly thing where the media gets
together and rose to the politicians and
all,
what's it called at the press club,
the,
uh,
my last correspondence,
the White House correspondence dinner.
Thanks.
When I watch all of this stuff and even
I saw you a couple of weeks ago at,
in the spin room at the debate in Vegas,
we were at the democratic debate there
and I've been around it a little more
lately.
I'm.
One of the things that I really do fear
is that the media and the politicians
are just in it too tightly that people
are just too friendly with each other.
They're actually,
you know,
we have so many instances of people that
are married to people on television and
they're the kids.
And this one or the uncle of that one on
all of this stuff.
Uh,
I'm pretty sure no one in your family's
pulling strings in politics.
Right?
Let's get that out of the way,
except for my cousin brock.
But that's,
of course he's your cousin,
of course these guys.
Right.
But really,
how do you see that as an actual threat
to democracy?
Because that I really see as a major
problem.
Uh,
I don't know if I would call it a threat
to democracy.
I do see it as um,
it's a little fake and phony to me.
Like,
you know,
it was great going to,
being invited to the White House
correspondence dinner,
but it was a lot more fun when I was
covering it and I can make fun of
people.
Right.
So how much does that make you bite your
tongue?
Because you want to go to the dinners,
right?
Like we've all been around.
I went to the White House Christmas
party,
right?
And because I knew the Obama from
Chicago and it was tough and I said this
before,
like when you know someone,
people I didn't know them that well.
They weren't my best friends,
but I knew them from around the way.
Right from being I was a local news
anchor and they were there,
they,
you know,
that would introduce them at chicken
dinners like emo state Senator Barack
Obama and Michelle,
and then his wife would always say,
Oh don,
stay out of trouble.
And I'm like,
who?
Me?
Why?
So to have to sort of criticize him on
policy and the things it was,
it was,
at first it was uncomfortable in
Michael,
he's the president and the buck stops
with him.
So I've got,
you know,
an ease,
black,
whatever.
I've got to do it.
I'm a journalist,
that was,
I took an oath and so when I saw him
sort of in an,
in an informal context and not like
throwing questions at him or seeing him
at the end a Bj and like yelling across
the room,
like,
how are you going to handle this?
And having them yell back when I had to
go and shake their hand and take a
picture with him,
I was like,
oh,
what are they going to say it?
So I walked up and you know,
and they were like,
hey,
you know,
you did the right thing by coming out.
And I was like thank you.
Right.
And so they get it,
they get it.
But it was a little weird and I felt
like I don't know if I should be that
close to winning in this sort of
situation to be partying with the
president or for that matter,
partying with some of the people,
you know,
when you go to the Oscars and all those
things.
I don't know,
I just feel like I kind of feel like
Wendy Williams,
right?
Who Sits on her purple chair and she
liked talks smack about everybody and
then when they see her or when she sees
him she's like,
oh.
Or I kind of feel like that a little
bit.
So don't you think that more you guys
need that sense?
Because I totally feel like everybody,
you know,
and it's not just,
I don't mean just the at the friendly
level,
but you know,
we don't,
we don't have to.
I'm not trying to name names or people
here,
but there are plenty of anchors that
literally used to work on campaigns for.
For President or I mean you can name
some names or look a little weird to me.
Look,
I mean somebody like a,
you know Stephanopoulos right there.
This
is Diane Sawyer.
There's a George will.
I mean even in George will is a
commentator,
a David Gergen.
He's accommodated Donna Brazil
commentator.
That's different.
But when you're a journalist,
you know there are plenty of journalists
who have worked for campaigns.
Yeah,
but when you're a commentator,
how,
how different do you actually think that
is?
So somebody like Don Dave,
but don't you think they have a certain
amount allegiance for a campaign that
they would,
that they worked on previously that they
can,
you know,
I think they do.
That's why we hire them because they not
because they have allegiance because
they have knowledge to that person or
will.
We will say,
Donna Brazil worked for the Al Gore
campaign.
You,
everybody knows that.
So she can offer insight,
but also with it,
unless you're crazy,
you know,
that her allegiance would be to,
um,
to Al Gore.
Uh,
I think it's totally different because
when you're a commentator,
you're hired to commentate as they say
or to comment.
Uh,
and to give your opinion as a
journalist,
you're not necessarily,
that's not your role.
Yeah.
But you're pretty much right.
I would say you're right in between
those two things.
Um,
I do it on CNN.
What I do is I do and more of a point of
view on I am hired as to give commentary
on the Tom Joiner morning show radio
show which had to be approved by CNN.
So I feel free and different in that
zone to give.
But when I'm on CNN I have to watch
myself because that's not exactly what I
do,
but everyone has a certain lens and
everyone has a certain background and
they have a point of view and I think
that's okay as a human being,
as long as you let people know that and.
But that's nothing new.
You know,
Merle Cronkite,
all those guys gave commentary.
Right?
Well,
I always do think that's funny when some
of these people on tv,
you'll say,
well,
I don't share any of my opinions.
And it's like,
that's pretty much impossible actually,
even if for no other reason than your
body language when you're talking to
somebody.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yes,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I don't see anything wrong with it,
especially if you declare it.
That's why I had,
you know,
when,
when people were saying,
oh,
Fox is to the right,
okay,
fine.
They let you know,
MSNBC is to the left.
Okay,
fine.
They let you know and we are neither
here.
We want to be objective at CNN,
but we don't want people to have an in
our objectivity to let people run all
over reality and truth.
No.
Yeah.
Um,
so I should tell everybody that right
before we started the recording here,
uh,
you said to me,
what are we going to talk about?
And I said to you that I knew with you I
wasn't going to have to,
you know,
a lot of times I'll tell them,
I guess our,
we're going to touch on these kinds of
things,
but I knew if you knew that you were
going to be cool with that,
so I hope that that alone,
I want my audience to know that because
I hope that alone will dispel some of
this stuff about sort of how a lot of
you guys have to operate or at least how
you have to operate.
Because [inaudible] the person that I
know off the camera is the same guy that
I know right this second.
Yeah,
I.
There you go.
And I don't want to know the exact
questions you're gonna ask me.
And most of that was just like,
Hey,
what are we gonna talk about what's
going on and what's.
No,
you didn't,
you didn't push me at all.
Don't do that or I'm going to get mad.
Yeah.
No.
And we don't do that with our subjects
either.
Like someone we're going to go
interview.
We don't give them the questions.
I mean,
I'm,
they'll say,
what are we going to talk about?
We're going to talk about you running
for president.
That's the.
Yeah.
GimMe a Gimme like your worst moment
with a candidate.
Like what's like the worst thing that's
ever.
Any real flub or did he ever really
offend anybody or anything like that?
No,
I mean,
one of the,
um,
one of the most contentious moments was
with Rand Paul.
I'm sure you remember that.
And I started this whole thing called no
talking points because I hate,
I hate,
I hate talking points and I hate the way
politicians answer questions.
So ask me a question,
just a simple question and I'm going to
be a politician.
A.
Does that,
your office that you're in right now?
Well,
when you talk about offices,
a grandmother taught me was that you
don't really own anything.
It's all shared.
It's all part of the American people own
everything.
Right?
And then you're just like,
okay,
are you going to answer the damn
question?
So the simple answer is yes,
this is my office.
Politicians have a hard time doing that.
So Rand Paul had did that with me and I
was just like,
I'm like,
look man,
could you stop telling me what you did
yesterday in Congress and would you do,
how do you feel about this,
do you hear the question that I'm asking
you?
And so then he got really upset and it
became really heated and so it was an
uncomfortable moment,
but it was also a very freeing moment to
me because I was like,
you know what,
I'm sick of this.
And so I set a marker there and so
everyone I had that came on had to
answer the question and they do now,
now I'm not going to badger people
because sometimes they just won't.
And I'll say okay.
And then I will say it is obvious that
you don't want to answer the question so
we will move on.
Right?
Because I don't want to waste the
audience time.
So that was probably an,
an uncomfortable moment that I have with
a candidate.
But then I just interviewed him two
hours,
three hours ago.
So it's all,
it's all good.
Yeah.
Do you ever bite your tongue though,
related to the fact that you want these
guys to come on again?
Because even when I was in the spin room
talking to,
talking to their representatives,
not even the candidates,
I did feel a little bit of,
you know,
I had huckabee's campaign on back on
there at the end,
the
for you,
but they all want to be on CNN.
Fair enough.
All going to come.
But yes,
I know where you're going with this.
And the thing is,
is not,
it's not.
So let me share a little secret with
you.
This is just between us.
So if you had that concern you had and
that's a very real concern and that.
And that's real because you do want
people to come back,
right?
So it's all in the way you asked the
question,
it's all in the tone and if I say,
why are you such a damn bleeding heart
liberal,
you'll go,
what do you mean?
So you can just go,
well,
you know,
that's a very liberal perspective.
Why?
Why do you feel that way?
Yeah,
it's the same question,
right?
Pretty much.
It's all in the way you asked it.
It's like asking a question with a smile
on your face.
It's all in the tone and you can do it
by complimenting.
It's like I know you pride yourself on
your politics and your liberalism.
So would you answer this question for
me?
Same thing.
Well that's the way you asked the
question
that sort of brings it back to we
started this sort of online versus
mainstream media thing because I'll see
a lot of times,
you know,
the online guys who aren't interviewing
these people who are commentating on it,
they'll be like,
Ahhh,
lemon didn't attack him for this or you
didn't do this or that.
And it's like,
well guess what?
He's the one that actually has to stand
there.
Do it,
get another interview in the future,
you know,
figure out how to get truth from people
that aren't going to give you a much
truth.
Uh,
so my point is it's easier said than
here's the thing.
It is,
it's not.
And it's not even that it's easier for
them to say it because there was not
necessarily the best way or the easiest
way because you want someone to continue
to sit there and the interview to answer
questions,
right?
Uh,
and you,
you also want,
you don't want to antagonize them.
And I'm also thinking about the viewer
because if I continue to antagonize
them,
the viewer gets no information.
That person shuts down and it's not good
for any of us.
Right?
So it's done.
So rather than what am I going to do,
stand up,
go over to the chair that the subject
was sitting in and ring their neck.
It's not,
it's not gonna happen.
So if you're,
if you're sitting there,
Dave Rubin,
and you don't want to answer a question,
what am I going to do?
Inject you with,
what do you call it?
Sodium,
sodium Pentothal to make you tell the
truth.
It's not gonna happen.
So you get as much as you can and then
you move on.
That's how it works.
All right,
I got one more for Ya.
But first,
have you ever touched wolf,
blitzers?
Beard?
I feel like I'd really today in that way
it was,
we gave each other a td hug and it was a
little weird,
like,
Oh yeah,
I'm convinced there's something,
there's something like the whole secret
to his success is the beard.
It's mad.
It's magic will be on my show at 10:00
PM.
So you have to watch.
Oh,
nice.
All right,
cool.
Uh,
all right,
well then my last question for you is
what's next?
Because I've,
I've seen this thing not to talk about
the rise that you didn't want to talk
about before,
but,
but I've seen it.
I flat out seen it.
So what's next man?
So I'm sure you've read.
Um,
so here's the thing,
people always ask me,
Oh,
what are you going to do next?
What's your,
you,
how long bought to get where I am.
So I'm just going to love this for
awhile.
Like I really,
I wake up every day and usually,
you know,
sometimes the first time I wake up as,
because an alarm goes off and it's time
for my editorial call.
And the first thing that's on my mind
every day as well.
What am I going to put on tv today that
is pretty freaking awesome.
So I'm in a really great spot.
I'm,
I live every moment in gratitude.
I am very happy.
I'm content.
I'm not complacent,
so I'm going to enjoy this for the
moment.
And I would have to say that the next
thing,
if I could think about it,
but best laid plans,
right?
It's probably a show that is more bill
Maher or Chelsea handler or something
like that where I can actually give a
point of view and actually say,
like you said,
shit or whatever it is that you said and
not have everybody going,
oh my gosh,
she can't.
I can't believe Don Lemon said that.
Well,
they're probably gonna do that either
way,
but uh,
yeah.
So that's probably.
If I had to think of something,
but who knows,
I will probably do this if all goes as
it's going now,
knock on wood,
you know,
God allow for the next 10 or 15 years
and that's not a bad thing.
Yeah.
Uh,
well listen,
I 100 percent.
You know,
how thrilled I am for your success and
our friendship and uh,
I look forward to our next adventure at
blondie's.
You can down some wings.
You,
you put me to shame.
I mean it was sad.
I had to cut back.
I was there this weekend.
Past weekend.
Yeah.
I only ate eight of my 10 wings.
Oh yeah.
I've ordered like two ordered double
owners when we've been together.
You literally,
you got a double order.
You had I think 48 wings on a plate.
No,
let me tell you this.
Let me tell you.
Um,
I used to be able to do that in my
twenties and thirties and forties and
now I can't do it.
Wait,
did you hit the big five?
Oh,
I thought you were 49.
I don't want to hear it.
Oh No,
you turned five.
Oh,
I'm a little behind you.
How far?
Uh,
I'm 39.
Oh Wow.
You're,
you're older than me.
I'm 37.
Wait a minute.
Something ain't right here.
Anyway.
You guys can catch Don weeknights on CNN
and pretty much wherever and whenever
breaking news happens.
Don.
Thanks a lot,
man.
Thanks.
Good to see you.
Did you to keep up the good work.